[Musik]
da zusammen und herzlich willkommen zur
zdf heute live mit ihrem live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen
und das ist heute abend der schulgipfel
im kanzleramt
denn wenn die korona pandemie vielleicht
auch irgendwas gutes hat wir mal
hingucken dann dass sie einige
schwachstellen aufgezeigt hat bei uns
zum beispiel an den schulen denn die
zustand der schulen ist in weiten teilen
doch ziemlich schwierig gerade was
digitalisierung angeht während der
schulschließungen im frühjahr ist
klargeworden es fehlt an digitalen
lernkonzepten das wird ein digitaler
ausstattung der schüler/innen lehrer
oder auch der schulen es gibt keine
lehrkräfte die digital lernen können
zumindest nicht in der masse die wir sie
wie wir sie brauchen und es geht
generell an lehrkräften in deutschland
es gibt eine oecd-studie die heißen
bildung auf einen blick und die
sonderauswertung dazu die zeit zu den
folgen der korona krise das
homeschooling in deutschland ganz schön
schwierig ist wir haben in anderen
ländern das wirklich besser hinbekommen
laut studie konnte nur etwa jeder zehnte
schule in deutschland adäquat beschult
werden und in der hintergrund lädt das
ist verena knoblauch lehrerin an einer
grundschule in nürnberg und
digitalisierungs expertin schönen abend
mit ihr wollen wir gleich reden über
genau die frage was muss bildung
eigentlich besser machen in sachen
digitalisierung und auch die silikon
situation gerade aus anlaß ist eben wie
gesagt der schulgipfel wo sich in berlin
heute abend bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel die bildungsministerien anja
karliczek spd schafft den saskia esken
und die kultusminister innen der länder
getroffen haben
frage erwarten sie von so einem gipfel
eigentlich irgendwas oder ist es für sie
eher so ein tropfen auf den heißen stein
bis heiße luft ach ja irgendwas würde
ich mir schon erwarten
ich bin gespannt was jetzt
herausgekommen ist bislang glaube ich
war relativ wenig was wir so mitgekriegt
haben ich habe das gefühl bislang war
das eher eine sache
was jede einzelne schule gemacht hat und
ich glaube wir würden uns alle hoffen
dass es jetzt ein paar vorgaben gibt
vielleicht auch ein paar klarere regeln
weiter machen soll
wir sprechen bei gleicher drüber ich
würde noch kunst sagen wenn wir alles
noch im livestream erwarten gleich soll
stefanie huber ich bei uns wird die
kamera treten bildungsministerin von
rheinland pfalz von der spd außerdem
präsidentin der kultusministerin der
kultusministerkonferenz
kultusministerkonferenz heißt ich glaub
ich offiziell das heißt federführend
jetzt wahrscheinlich auch bei den
beratungen wird uns dann hoffentlich
gleich erzählen was dabei herausgekommen
ist und unser hauptstadtkorrespondent
theo koll ist natürlich auch vor ort
wird man vielleicht noch mal das ganze
ein ordner fragen dann kommentare wie
immer gerne in die dafür vorgesehenen
dann kästchen oder einmal hier an diese
e mail adresse das wird dann auch zu mir
durchgereicht so sie haben schon gesagt
frau knoblauch bis jetzt hat das jeder
schule irgendwie alleine gemacht wie
haben sie das denn bis jetzt an ihrer
schule gemacht mit corona unter
digitalisierung kann ich muss sagen ich
war auch letztes schuljahr selber nicht
als klassleiter und in der schule
eingesetzt insofern waren die kollegen
und kolleginnen dann tatsächlich mehr
eingespannt an der schule
ich bin als medienpädagogische beraterin
bei uns in nürnberg tätig und habe quasi
auch alle grund- und mittelschulen
beraten
und da mir wirklich angefangen möglichst
von anfang an möglichst zeitnah eine
hotline einzuführen wo wir wirklich alle
anfragen der schulen versucht haben zu
beantworten oder links fiel um
datenschutz geschichten das heißt welche
plattform darf ich jetzt nutzen was darf
ich da machen was darf ich das nicht
machen
wir haben sehr schnell angefangen in
online fortbildungen anzubieten um eben
den kolleginnen und kollegen mittel an
die hand zu geben wie man jetzt
unterrichten kann und so ist es im
endeffekt bei uns an der schule
aufgelaufen das heißt die kolleginnen
und kollegen haben wir gesucht erstmal
die schülerinnen und schüler zu
kontaktieren und dann unterricht
durchzuführen aufrecht zu erhalten ist
das denn tatsächlich schon der digitaler
unterricht gewesen den sie sich
vorstellen oder den sie versuchen in
ihren fortbildungen an ihren webinaren
den lehrer innen nahe zu bringen
oder war das noch eher so dass gute alte
arbeitsblatt das dann irgendwie gescannt
und dann weiter gemeldet wurde zum
ausfüllen
ich glaube monaten hat der
fernunterricht an mancher stelle ganz
hervorragend funktioniert und ich glaube
an ganz vielen stellen das auch ganz
kolossal gescheitert
sie sind für sie hervorragende der
unterricht aus können sie das man am
beispiel irgendwie illustrieren
also ich glaube hervorragender
fernunterricht ein bisschen lebens
stellen passiert wo vorher auch schon
die infrastruktur daran dass kolleginnen
und kollegen erfahrungen schon packen
mit online unterricht wo auch die vielen
schüler erfahrungen hatten weil ich
glaube dass das utopisch zu denken dass
wenn ich das vorher noch nie gemacht
habe dass ich dann mit dem finger
schnipsen und das funktioniert also das
liegt dann ja schon einmal einen
technischen geschichten nicht
funktioniert an und natürlich dann aber
auch an vorwissen und an erfahrung
jetzt habe ich ja gerade schon mal
gefragt wie das bei ihnen an der schule
aussieht sie haben selber gesagt sie
unterrichten gabe nicht aber trotzdem
können sie vielleicht ein bisschen
erzählen wie der grafiker bedingungen
sind darum wird es ja beim schulgipfel
leute auch gehe nicht nur um
digitalisierung sondern auch um die
frage wie die hygienevorschriften
eigentlich aussehen sollen wie das ganze
durchgesetzt werden kann was auch die
große fragen des lüftens angeht wie ist
das bei ihnen was beobachten sie ihren
den schulen ist das jetzt eine sache man
hat die fenster auf und hat schon jacken
an oder wie wir das durch umgesetzt als
ich unterrichte schon bloß nicht in der
klasse leitung ich bin nur einen tag an
der schule
bei uns ist es so wir lüften regelmäßig
dann bis guten wetters unterrichten wir
eigentlich momentan auch noch bei
ständig gehört so können sich unsere
fenster auch öffnen wir wissen glaube
ich alle aus berichten das ist
andernorts auch anders aussieht und das
nicht möglich ist
ansonsten ja wir haben ausreichend seife
und papierhandtücher auch das
funktioniert ganz gut
und ansonsten glaube ich dass ich für
alle schulen sprechen kann wenn ich auch
sagt dass wir über alle froh sind wir
sonst hilft die hygienemaßnahmen
möglichst gut umzusetzen
ich habe ja einen kommentar schon von
der pike auf youtube beschreibt ich
arbeite an einer grundschule im
problembezirk fehlende sprachkenntnisse
armut fast 98 prozent
migrationshintergrund für uns ist
digitalisierung ein ganz fern ferner
wunschtraum denkt da jemand daran haben
sie auch solche erfahrungen gemacht
ja natürlich
also ich glaube das ist das was uns auch
ganz viel bauchschmerzen immer bereitet
hat zu wissen dass wir nicht alle kinder
gleich gut erreichen können
das liegt zum einen an der technischen
ausstattung natürlich zum anderen aber
auch gerade weil grundschulen natürlich
auch daran ob die kinder zu hause die
unterstützung von den eltern haben weil
ich glaube dass das auch klar dass er
von cancún schüler erwarten können dass
der jetzt wird sich zu hause sitzt und
völlig selbst denn nicht alleine da ein
online unterricht organisiert oder auch
die arbeitsblätter ausdruckt oder was
auch immer damit zu tun hat also da
finden wir in der grundschule natürlich
immer noch mal ganz massiv auch die
zusammenarbeit mit den eltern angewiesen
und natürlich ist uns dann aber auch
bewusst dass das für die eltern eine
ganz unglaubliche belastung ist normal
warnt weber im home office oder haben um
ihre existenz gebannt und das dann dafür
viele schule eben auch gerade nicht ganz
vorne die forderte priorität hat ist
glaube ich auch nachvollziehbar dass ich
in der ersten klasse letztes schuljahr
nur und wir haben gekämpft wirklich das
ist eine sache die wird mich auch oder
uns interessieren hier schreibt bitte
mal in die kommentare wie eure oder ihre
erfahrungen waren als lehrer als
elternteile oder auch als schüler und
schülerinnen uns wurde wir uns schon
gefragt ob wir auch die schüler innen zu
wort kommen lassen die werden gleich zu
wort kommen und nicht im live gespräch
das haben wir heute abend dann nicht
mehr geschafft ich kann aber schon mal
verraten das sind heute journal ein
schüler zu wort kommen wird
heute abend weil natürlich müssen alle
gefragt werden die beteiligt sind aber
ich würde wirklich gerne wissen was so
die erfahrungen von unseren zuschauern
hier sind und für alle die gerade erst
dazu kommen wir sprechen heute abend
über den schulgipfel der zur stunde im
kanzleramt noch stattfindet aber gleich
zu ende sein soll wir warten darauf dass
die präsidentin der
kultusministerkonferenz stefanie huber
bildungsministerin von rheinland pfalz
für unsere kamera dreht und uns einmal
erzählt was dort raus gekommen ist und
der sie auch ein paar fragen stellen
können und ich wäre gerade mit
ferienclub lauch lehrerin an einer
nürnberger grundschule und
medienpädagogische beraterin bildet auch
lehrer innen aus die mit digitalen
unterricht noch nicht so viel zu tun
hatten das war eine frage die haben wir
auch heute schon mehrfach bekommen wie
kann man denn so digitale lehrer außer
digitalen muffel unter den lehrern die
kriegt man die dahin dass die
tatsächlich sich jetzt auch diesen
ominösen whiteboards und den tablets
nähern
also ich glaube es ist wichtig gerade
bei der digitalen muscheln wenn man sie
so nennen möchte erst mal nachzufragen
wo man das überhaupt nicht weil ich
glaube es gibt nicht den digital muschel
es gibt sicherlich unterschiedliche
gründe die einen haben vielleicht
wirklich berührungsängste weil ich auch
angst haben da was falsch zu machen und
auch wichtig zu zeigen zum einen dass es
kein hexenwerk ist und zum anderen aber
auch dass die welt nicht untergehen wenn
es vielleicht nicht funktionieren aber
haben sie das gefühl dass es ist es also
ist es eine eintagsfliege oder ist es
eher eine mentalitätsfrage woran liegt
das wenn jemand sagt ich mag das nicht
ich habe vielleicht sorge ich habe angst
ich hab einfach keine lust
also ich glaube es ist eine
mentalitätsfrage
ich glaube man sagt so gerne das ist
eine altersfrage man sich dann selber so
ein bisschen aus der verantwortung
nehmen kann man also bald einmal die
ganzen jungen lehrer lehrerinnen
nachkommen und dann hat sich das problem
erledigt ich glaube so einfach ist es
nicht
ich liebe es
die kolleginnen und kollegen die
wirklich absolut motiviert und
interessiert sind und die total 14 und
sich da ein arbeiten und das wirklich
auch können wollen und genau so gibt es
kolleginnen kollegen die von der uni
kommen und eigentlich wenig erfahrung
haben und auch vielleicht auch noch gar
nicht die notwendigkeit sehen was sich
da einzuarbeiten also für mich ist das
keine frage des alters
ich habe hier auch ein kommentar des
albrecht auf facebook schreibt also hier
bei uns in ihr die lehrer die digitalen
muschel aber auch einen einwand von
olthoff genie manche gar manche eltern
haben davon hat keine ahnung und müssen
arbeiten was macht man dann mit denen
man kann ja eltern schlecht dazu zwingen
dass sie jetzt auch seminare machen in
denen sie digitales lernen oder
betreuung von kindern zu hause beim
lernen lernen oder klar
das weiß ich vorher auch schon nicht
gerade der komplette locker und war da
war zu hause mama und papa im home
office mit anderen sachen beschäftigt
ich glaube das muss man sich auch vor
augen führen dass man auch als lehrer
lehrerin nicht erwarten kann
was zu hause jetzt mich alles nur eine
schule dreht und die eltern auf jeden
fall hier bei fuß stehen und das ganze
organisieren obwohl man natürlich auch
die mithilfe auf die zusammenarbeit mit
den eltern auch angewiesen ist und ich
glaube das ist ganz wichtig die
kommunikation zu suchen den kontakt zu
suchen erst mal raus zu finden wie
finden die verhältnisse bei meiner
klasse zu hause also wie ist die
ausstattung was können die eltern
unterstützen und was können sie auch
nicht da gibt es keine patentlösungen
die für alle funktioniert also wird er
brauchen wir individuelle lösungen und
da sind gerade dann die als cluster hat
und einfach auch gefragt erst mal raus
zu finden wie sie zu hause aus wie sind
die bedingungen um dann dementsprechend
auch den unterricht darauf anzupassen
hier gibt's ein kommentar der passt dazu
von manuela maus bea auf facebook als
elternteil wurde nichts wurde nichts
gemacht die lehrer sind nicht geschult
und unterricht virtuell zu gestalten
geschweige denn dass die schulen alle
schüler digitalen ausrüsten ausreden
dass es nicht möglich ist gibt es so
viele wie sand am meer wenn man es etwas
möchte dann kann es jeder ist es
tatsächlich so einfach frau knoblauch
also ich habe auch heute abend schauer
mit einem lehrer auf instagram
gesprochen
ob blume der sagte wir haben halt total
viele aufgaben als lehrer und
lehrerinnen mittlerweile und dann kommt
das nach oben drauf dann muss man das
verstehen dass manche lehrer einfach
sagen sie schaffen das nicht mehr
was braucht das da von der politik an
unterstützung ich habe vor müssen mit
reingehört und ich glaube was er gesagt
hat dass man einfach auch die zeit
braucht und nicht mein land
auseinanderzusetzen das ganz wichtig
weil wenn ich bis oben hin mit anderen
aufgaben voll bin habe ich einfach
keinen kopf darum zu kümmern
und ich glaube was ganz wichtig wäre
wäre auch so ein bisschen rückendeckung
und unterstützung dass man vielleicht
auch wirklich verbindliche aussagen
kriegt von von den stellen die
verantwortlich sind
welches tool darf ich denn verwenden um
zum beispiel eine video-konferenz zu
machen dass ich da nicht jeder
schulleiter wieder einzeln entscheiden
muss was nutzt bei den schule und im
zweifelsfall muss eltern kopf hinhalten
wenn dann datenschützer kommen und sich
dann darüber beschweren also ich glaube
da rückendeckung und ein paar vorgaben
macht man wirklich nutzen darf wäre sehr
hilfreich gewesen wenn das von anfang an
gegeben hätte es gibt hier eine frage
auf youtube kann man auf meinen rechner
schalten von macmaster hab ich mal
markiert hier wir brauchen online
lernplattformen wo lehrer als
lernbegleiter agieren können schreibt er
oder sie gibt es solche online
lernplattformen nicht schon frau
knobloch
ja es gibt lernplattformen dass wir in
bayern wir haben mädels es gibt so viel
elend rhein weist also es ist so eine
ländersache noch die das bundesamt
machte seine eigenen lernplattform und
die funktionieren unterschiedlich gut
glaube ich habe ich denke man braucht
eine lernplattform ist es sehr hilfreich
eine lernplattform zu haben ich denke
aber so sagen super wir haben eine
lernplattform damit ist das ganze
abgehakt und es läuft so einfach ist das
halt nicht
aber ist das nicht auch ein problem dass
jedes bundesland seine eigenen
lernplattform hat so da kommt jetzt die
katze die hatten wir soeben schon die
ganze zeit als wir uns nicht erhalten
haben das müssen sie die arme hochhalten
glaube ich damit alle zuschauer die
sehen können katzen dem livestream
basierte erfreut
besser geht's doch
bekannte es bei jeder online fortbildung
eigentlich dabei sein könnte auch bei
unternehmen aber die frage stellen
wollte ist es nicht vielleicht auch
gerade das das problem dass jedes
bundesland sein eigenes ding macht eine
andere plattform benutzt und wenn man
irgendwie versuchen würde das zu
vereinheitlichen
dann würde es vielleicht auch schneller
gehen weil einfach erfahrungen
ausgetauscht werden können zwischen den
unterschiedlichen bundesländern
ich denke das wäre unglaublich wichtig
und hilfreich wenn es noch mehr gemacht
wird also es wird ja gemacht und das
wird zusammengearbeitet
aber ich denke es wird ganz oft an
vielen stellen das gleiche gemacht weil
jedes bundesland das gleiche nochmal
macht und das glaube ich wäre wirklich
hilfreich wenn man da einfach die die
ressourcen bindet und damit kriegt es
immer wieder auf twitter mit da ist ein
reger austausch was unterrichtskonzepte
und auch digitalen unterricht betrifft
und da funktioniert es super unter den
lehrern noch da kommt aber die forderung
wenn man jetzt zum beispiel die ok
das bundesland hat welche online lern
pose veröffentlich oder andere kollegen
fragen mich warum können wir nicht auch
daran teilnehmen
die habe ich einen kommentar von anna
birgit book auf facebook wir brauchen
kein online lernen wir brauchen kann der
lernplattform was antworten sie denn da
was brauchen wir denn dann
wahrscheinlich würde diese kommentatoren
sagen den guten alten frontalunterricht
oder der unterricht den mann hat jetzt
so hat einen lehrer mit 25 bis 30
kindern und alle gemeinsam das ist ja
auch das was im grunde die
kultusminister innen anstreben auch die
bundesregierung hat gesagt sie möchte
alles dafür tun um einen weiteren doktor
und der schulen zu verhindern
darum soll es auch heute abend bei dem
stücke für gegangen seien aber
tatsächlich gibt es da ja auch noch in
teilen der bevölkerung in eine
grundlegende skepsis gegen diese art des
lernens was ist denn der vorteil für sie
daran
also ich meine ganz generell ich würde
auch keine neuen look down also ganz
bestimmt nicht wirklich als lehrerin und
auch als mama wirklich vor keine neuen
lockdown gäbe ich glaube aber digital zu
unterrichten bzw digitale medien in den
unterricht mit einzubeziehen ist nicht
eine frage von carola das wirklich gerne
darauf reduziert
momentan haben wir das gebraucht wird
fernunterricht aber eigentlich wollen
wir das gar nicht
im prinzip müssen uns bewusst machen wir
leben in einer kultur lingen starken
digitalität geprägt ist und ganz
unabhängig von corona und von
fernunterricht präsenz sind unterricht
hybrid unterricht oder was es alles gibt
ist es so dass wir die aufgabe haben als
schule die kinder oder die die
jugendlichen auch auf diese gesellschaft
vorzubereiten und da gehört es zum einen
mit dazu die kompetenzen mitzugeben die
chancen auch zu erkennen und zu nutzen
die dann drin stecken und natürlich auch
die gefahren die herausforderungen zu
erkennen und damit umzugehen
was heißt das konkret also wie kann ich
mir das vorstellen wenn sie also ich
glaube muss ein unterscheiden dass ganz
generell zwischen online unterricht und
digitalem lernen das ist das einer
digitales lernen quasi in der schule
aber mit digitalen geräten online lernen
halt dann alle auseinander und auf
distanz aber wenn wir mal dieses
digitale lernen dieses digitaler
unterrichten uns angucken was heißt das
denn ganz konkret also wenn meine
tochter bei ihnen in der schulklasse
dann digital lernt was macht dir dann
spielt hier die ganze zeit auf lernen
als auf dem tablett rum oder was macht
sie vielleicht müsste man wirklich
tatsächlich als erstes mal klären was
nicht heißt also gerade in der
grundschule begegnen mir ganz viele
vorurteile
ja wo dann eben gesagt wenn manche
zwischen die alle in der schule die
ganze zeit ich soll doch erst mal lesen
und schreiben und und damit rechnen
lernen und ich glaube ganz wichtig sich
zu verinnerlichen dass es nicht darum
geht alles was man jetzt vorher analog
gemacht hat jetzt einfach digital zu
ersetzen
also sagen wir mal ich nehme das thema
wald im unterricht durch er wenn ich
jetzt sage ich habe tablet ich kann am
film darüber angucken ist super dann
spare ich mir den ausflug in den wald
dann sind wir glaube ich alle eigentlich
dass der größte quatsch lehrer die mich
machen kann
tolle idee oder man könnte vielleicht
mit virtuellen mit mit virtuellen
headsets arbeiten und man kann man
virtuell durch den wald gehen
ich meine es kann nicht zusätzlich
machen aber trotzdem muss ich in den
wald gehen und ich muss mich im wald
liegt und ich fast die bäume an also das
gehört dazu und das möchte keiner
streichen
genau so und jetzt bin ich wieder in der
grundschule das thema gewichte
man hat in der klasse so eine große
balkenwaage wo man auch die eine seite
ist ein federmäppchen bild auf die
andere seite in die gewichte und man
sieht wie schwer das ist
da gibt es bestimmt ne obwohl es dann
auch gewichte hin und herziehen kann
aber das ist nicht das gleiche das muss
ich einfach in die hand nehmen und darum
geht aber eben nicht das ist mir glaube
ich das erste was man klären muss man
jetzt nicht bedeutet und was es digitale
medien ermöglichen für mich machen ganz
anders zu machen oder wirklich auch
dinge zu tun die ich vorher nicht tun
konnte ganz einfaches beispiel ich kann
plötzlich sprache festhalten sprache
etwas was ja eigentlich sehr flüchtig
ist ich kann das ich festhalten ich kann
man eigene sprache anhören
ich kann mir im englischunterricht
wörterbücher erstellen wo ich mit meiner
eigenen sprache diese wörter anspreche
fotos dazu suche ich kann reportagen vor
dem greenscreen drehen und so tun als ob
ich gerade mit einem anderen land oder
auch in anderen zeiten und von dort
berichtet also ich kann einfach sachen
anders machen als vorlagen
es tut sich ein bisschen was in berlin
ich habe hier gerade schon eine
pressemitteilung rein gereicht bekommen
die bundeskanzlerin merkel im austausch
mit den kultusministerien und ministern
der länder über maßnahmen zu stärken des
schulsystems in der korona pandemie so
heißen solche pressemitteilung immer
wenn wir sie bekommen und da sind
folgende handlungsstränge identifiziert
wurden
ein einheitlicher rahmen für die
schulischen infektionsschutz maßnahmen
das heißt dass deutlich erstmal so dass
in allen schulen in deutschland
das einheitlich geregelt sein soll
zügiger weiterer ausbau der glasfaser
internetanbindung für alle schulen
da hatte ich jetzt gesagt dass sie
applaudieren mit ihrer katze hochhalten
glasfaser internet macht ok ausstattung
aller lehrkräfte und bei bedarf von
kindern mit geeigneten endgeräten beides
das mittel das vom bundes um 202 x 500
millionen arbeiteten digital pacyna also
digital parkschule wird erweitert und
noch mehr geld und dann sollen alle
lehrkräfte und bei bedarf auch kinder
geeignete endgeräte bekommen
da haben wir gleich noch mal ein
interessantes fakten stück dazu das ist
zwar diese mittel gibt es aber die ganz
häufig nicht abgerufen werden
dann will sich der bund beteiligen
das technische administration
generatoren ausgebildet werden damit die
digitale infrastruktur an den schulen
auch tatsächlich pflegen können 500
millionen euro soll es dafür geben das
klingt ja auch schon mal nicht so
schlecht und es soll kompetenzzentren
geben für digitales und digital
gestütztes unterrichten
die dann schulen vor ort beraten das
machen sie ja im grunde schon so ein
bisschen in nürnberg na also die schulen
beraten lehrer beraten sind seines
weines 1 prozent zentrum und schritt 6
ist jetzt ganz interessant frau knobloch
da haben wir gerade gesprochen darüber
dass die länder alle ihr eigenes
süppchen kochen was die lernplattform
angeht und da heißt es jetzt dass es
eine schrittweise entwicklung einer
bildungsplattform geben soll durch den
bund koordiniert damit die bestehenden
systeme der länder miteinander vernetzt
werden und das ziel ist dann dass die
bildungsinhalte in allen
bildungsbereichen bereitgestellt werden
soll also da wird dann das tatsächlich
diese vernetzung geben
hier wird die firma gesprochen haben
aber schrittweise entwicklung weiß ich
immer schon das kann bei jahre dauern
und soll hochwertige digitale
bildungsmedien geben
insbesondere open educational resources
das müssen sie uns mal übersetzen das im
prinzip inhalte die man erstellt hat und
die von allen die das gerne möchten frei
genutzt werden dürfen auch verändert
werden dürfen
die eben nicht anders wie bei schönbuch
verlagen wo man ja dann das urheberrecht
beachten muss sind das eben materialien
die erstellt wurden damit man sie weiter
verwenden darf uns frei teilen danach
auch so knobloch ich höre stefanie
grubich bildungsministerin rheinland
pfalz ist vor unserer kamera bereit ich
sage erst mal vielen dank und dann
schalten wir nach berlin ich hoffe dass
ich mich hören kann
da ist sie wundervolle einen schönen
abend danke dass sie heute abend noch
zeit haben es hat ein bisschen länger
gedauert hohen aufwands gelegen
na ja wir hatten einiges zu besprechen
das sind ja ich sag mal nicht ganz
einfache themen die wir auf der agenda
hatten komplexe themen und deshalb haben
wir ein bisschen länger gedauert aber
ich glaube es hat sich gelohnt ich habe
mir jetzt mal angeschaut was sie
beschlossen haben das ist sehr viel von
digitalisierung die rede mehr geld und
mehr ausbildung ich hatte damit
gerechnet dass es eher um hygiene regeln
geht diskussion ums lüften und das bei
mehr darüber geredet wird was ist denn
dabei rausgekommen
dann wird uns dieser maßnahme anschauen
also wir haben uns die hygiene
wir haben die hygienemaßnahmen noch
einmal vorgestellt wir haben ja ein
gemeinsames konzept der kmk für die
hygiene regeln erarbeitet das haben wir
jetzt noch mal aktualisiert und wir
werden am mittwoch ein expertengespräch
machen zum lüften auf kmk ebene das
haben wir schon anberaumt weil wir dort
einfach auch noch mal über die fragen
die im zusammenhang mit dem lüften jetzt
auch bei vielen menschen entstanden sind
und sachkundigen und fachkundigen rat
holen wollen das heißt sie können
unseren zuschauerinnen noch nicht sagen
ob ihre kinder im winter frieren werden
weil alle zehn minuten stoß gelüftet
wird also alle zehn minuten wird ganz
bestimmt nicht gelüftet
wir haben ja bisher schon regelung zum
lüften bei uns in den hygiene konzepten
drin die sind noch unterschiedlich
manche regeln nach 45 minuten einmal
stoßlüften fünf minuten andere sagen
nach 20 minuten fünf minuten stoßlüften
und wir wissen alle die kinder werden
nicht sicherlich nicht erfrieren
es ist gut auch frische luft zu haben
und ich denke wir werden dazu guten und
zu auch für die kinder gut tragbaren
lösungen kommen meine tochter beschwert
sich dass es kalt ist und dass sie dem
unterricht von nebenan man mitbekommt
weil alle türen auf sein müssen ist das
nicht auch ein problem
als wir während des unterrichtes müssen
die türen ja nicht offen sein sondern es
geht nur um die 5 minuten in denen
gelüftet wird
das sind im moment besondere zeit nur
der unterricht kann ich eins zu eins
stattfinden wir vor der pandemie
stattgefunden hat das ist ganz klar
und deshalb braucht man auch in
besonderen zeiten manchmal auch
besondere maßnahmen ich glaube wichtig
ist das für die schulen offen halten
können und dass wir insgesamt es
schaffen dass die schulen den
präsenzunterricht der für alle so
wichtig ist für schülerinnen und schüler
aber auch für lehrkräfte dass wir den
gewährleisten können und da müssen wir
manchmal auch zu maßnahmen greifen die
vielleicht nicht völlig einfach sind
oder die wenig die wir vorher nicht
ergriffen hatten vor der pandemie wir
haben frau habe ich ein paar schüler
innen gefragt was die eigentlich zu den
massnahmen denken was sie in diesen
zeiten bedrückt und das haben sie uns
geantwortet ich wünsche mir vor allem
dass mehr auf und schülerinnen und
schüler eingegangen wird
viele von uns sind gar nicht beteiligt
wenn es darum geht ein hygiene konzept
zu erstellen oder dinge zu planen und
dabei sind wir es doch die mehrzahl der
leute an der schule ausmachen nicht
beschäftigt schüler mit der schulweg am
meisten
welche leider oftmals von einigen
wenigen die maske nicht getragen und in
den bussen abstand halten auch nicht
möglich ist und gerade auch an den
bushaltestellen sich die mengen extrem
zusammen entstehen ohne maske und ich
möchte als schüler nicht meine
mitmenschen gefährden und das regt mich
dann doch durchaus zur sorge an wenn ich
da an gerüstet werden unterricht kann
sehr oft nicht im notwendigen umfang
erteilt werden
hygienemaßnahmen werden teils schlecht
kommuniziert und von homeschooling und
digitalisierung braucht mir gar nicht
erst anfangen
all das könnte sich aber sehr schnell
ändern indem man den schulen vor ort die
notwendigen entscheidungsfreiheiten gibt
und wir sprechen mit stefanie grubich
bildungsministerin in rheinland-pfalz
was sagen sie den kindern auch solche
sorgen und ängste naja also einmal sage
ich den jungen menschen wir beteiligen
sie schon wir haben in rheinland pfalz
jetzt eine anhörung zum lüften in dieser
woche da werden wir auch die
landesschülervertretung mit dabei haben
weil wir wollen dass auch sie mit
einbezogen werden wir besprechen die
dinge mit ihnen und wollen die dann auch
gemeinsam vorantreiben das ist das eine
das andere ist die sorge über diejenigen
die keine masken tragen die teile ich
auch ich finde es gehört dazu dass man
nicht
in der schule diszipliniertes sondern
dass man vor allen dingen auch außerhalb
der schule die masken trägt abstand hält
die hygiene regeln einhält das ist ganz
ganz wichtig denn wir sehen dass die
infektion in die schule rein gebracht
werden und nicht in den schulen
entstehen aber möglichkeiten schüler zu
sanktionieren die sieht statt masse
nicht tragen wollen oder sich falsch
verhalten geht es ja so nicht oder also
im rahmen der der schule gibt es
natürlich möglichkeiten schülerinnen und
schüler zu sanktionieren das ist so wie
in anderen bereichen auch schülerinnen
und schülern sich nicht an die regel
halten
das ist ganz klar dass das in schule
auch geht mit den entsprechenden
verweisen ermahnungen was immer die
einzelne schule da sozusagen auf der
agenda wir gucken mal aufs thema
digitalisierung war dann scheint doch
ein großes thema heute abend bei ihnen
digital packt schule gab es im letzten
jahr
es gab viel geld das wurde teilweise
aber nicht abgerufen meine kollegin
fahrer schlink hat das mal für uns
zusammengefasst
über ein jahr nach beginn des digital
parks schule fehlt noch immer geld wo es
wirklich gebraucht wird in den
klassenzimmern zahlen von ende juni
zeigen eine überschaubare jahresbilanz
von den fünf milliarden euro fördergeld
des bundes für digitalen unterricht sind
von den ländern insgesamt nur 15,7
millionen euro abgerufen worden das sind
etwa 0,3 prozent so waren im juni
lediglich in neun bundesländer überhaupt
mittel geflossen und dabei gibt es unter
ihnen auch noch erhebliche unterschiede
musterschüler sind bremen mit gut
sechseinhalb millionen und hamburg mit
gut fünfeinhalb millionen euro
schlusslicht mit knapp 30.000 euro ist
rheinland-pfalz noch weniger nämlich gar
nicht abgerufen haben alle übrigen
bundesländer 0 euro für die
digitalisierung im klassenzimmer
obwohl das geld vom bund bereit stünde
eine bilanz die zum nachsitzen
auffordert yahoo bietet in ihrem
bundesland nur so wenig von diesen
mitteln abgerufen 30.000 euro in
rheinland-pfalz es denn nicht viel
also seit dem 30 06
hat sich die welt deutlich weiter
gedreht und wir sind in rheinland pfalz
an einer ganz anderen stelle angelangt
nämlich bei über ich glaube 30 millionen
die wir jetzt mit den anträgen belegt
haben
das ist ein unterschied wir haben drei
monate corona gehabt und in der zeit in
der wir also vom 30 vom 30
oder 13 drittens die schulen zugemacht
haben bis zum 30.06 war dass die korona
zeit die mit umfasst war und in der zeit
haben schulträger aber haben auch die
schulen viele andere dinge zu tun gehabt
die ganz wichtig waren und die sind
natürlich in der zeit auch nicht dazu
gekommen mit dem pädagogische konzepte
zu schreiben und die anträge zu
schreiben jetzt hat sich das deutlich
geändert und ich habe mich bei der
bundesbildungsministerin dafür
eingesetzt und zwar erfolgreich dass
auch die medien pädagogischen konzepte
erst später nachgereicht werden können
und wir sehen jetzt in allen ländern
dass es deutlich mehr anträge gibt und
dass wir da sehr sehr viel schneller
vorankommen
das heißt frank das so richtig ist weil
erst das war zu kompliziert diese gelder
zu bekommen tatsächlich oder das hat so
viel aufwand ist zum teil zum teil haben
die anträge waren die anträge oder das
schreiben von anträgen zu aufwändig
deshalb haben wir auch die verfahren
noch einmal vereinfacht damit für
darsteller sind sozusagen auch die
voraussetzungen jetzt nochmal mit blick
darauf verändert dass die schulen ja
während der pandemie auch schon richtig
gesehen haben was brauche ich noch mal
an digitalen medien in welche richtung
entwickelt entwickelt sich meine schule
weiter und das bedeutet natürlich dass
auch diese medien pädagogischen konzepte
die sehr zeitaufwendig sind später
geschrieben werden können
jetzt wissen die schulen in welche
richtung sie sich entwickeln das ist das
eine und das andere
lassen sie mich das gerade noch anfügen
ist das geld wird erst dann abgerufen
bei der sozusagen verbaut ist das heißt
wenn der glasfaseranschluss gelegt ist
und wenn die schulen entsprechend
ausgestattet sind und das dauert
natürlich zwischen antrag also schreiben
eines antrags antragstellung und dann
wenn der bagger oder der elektriker oder
wer auch immer vor ort ist und die dinge
dann an bringt und dann fließt das geld
erst ab das heißt wir haben eine sehr
viel höhere antrag summe als wir am ende
im moment abgeflossenen gelder haben
aber da hat sich wie gesagt seit dem
30.06 deutlich etwas verändert
haben sie noch zeit für eine kurze frage
ja es gibt eine frage von einem user auf
youtube bildung ist in deutschland eine
frage der sozialen herkunft was wollen
sie während der chor ohne krise dagegen
tun und warum hatte es nicht vorher
priorität
also bildung hat denke ich in den
meisten ländern vielleicht sogar oder
ganz bestimmt sogar in allen ländern
priorität wir sehen dass zum beispiel an
den haushalten der haushalt den ich habe
ist ein viertel des gesamten haushalts
ist der größte haushalt das heißt ich
habe am meisten geld für bildung
gegenüber den anderen ministerien das
ist aber nur das eine das andere ist
dass wir für schülerinnen und schüler
die schwierigere startbedingungen haben
jetzt die endgeräte haben die laptops
oder tablets damit die schüler die eben
von zu hause so etwas nicht mitbekommen
da gleichgestellt werden ich habe mich
dafür eingesetzt dass wir auch
lernsysteme entwickeln die feedback
geben die schülerinnen und schüler auch
unterstützen die vielleicht zu hause
nicht das umfeld haben damit sie die
rückmeldung bekommen damit sie hilfe
bekommen so dass sie eben auch selber
sich dann zu hause weiter entwickeln
können und in der schule dann natürlich
entsprechend den unterricht bekommen
ich glaube wir müssen gerade auch in den
ferien wir machen in rheinland pfalz
noch mal ein angebot in den ferien für
schülerinnen und schüler die
nachholbedarf haben gucken und wir haben
auch vereinbart mit dem bund das ist
jetzt eine flatrate gibt die
verschiedene telefonunternehmen anbieten
das heißt für schülerinnen und schüler
gibt es künftig für zehn euro im monat
eine flatrate und führt die schülerinnen
und schüler die ich sag mal finanziell
aus einer finanziell schwierigen
haushalt kommen kann sie sogar
übernommen werden so dass wir da
wirklich gerade für diese gruppe viel
erreicht haben und das ist auch ganz
wichtig dass diese gruppe die gleichen
bildungschancen haben wie alle anderen
aber die frage vom user warum bayer auch
warum hatte das nicht schon vorher
priorität ich legt noch einen drauf
musste erst eine pandemie kommen bis der
bund tätig wird und all diese
möglichkeiten in die wege leitet
also die digitalisierung war schon immer
ein thema ich glaube wir hatten vor der
pandemie überhaupt nie die vorstellung
dass wir mal quasi den präsenzunterricht
zu 100 prozent ersetzen müssen und dass
wir in ein system gehen müssen wo wir
wirklich auch immer wieder da rechnen
müssen dass einzelne klassen vielleicht
auch eine schule zu 100 prozent digital
unterricht machen muss und das hat allen
einen unglaublichen schub gegeben
den schülerinnen und schülern aber vor
allen dingen auch den lehrerinnen und
lehrern und es hat glaube ich allen auch
in der politik deutlich gemacht wie
wichtig es ist dass wir bei der
digitalisierung vorankommen und das
können die länder und die schulträger
nicht alleine machen sondern dazu
brauchen wir auch den bund und ich bin
froh dass wir jetzt auch noch mal
anderthalb milliarden euro vom bund
zugesagt bekommen haben für die
digitalisierung der schulen für
endgeräte für schülerinnen und schüler
aber auch für lehrkräfte damit wir eben
diese dinge weiter vorantreiben können
und das was wir heute im kanzleramt
vereinbart haben sind auch
vereinbarungen die eben mittel und
langfristig die digitale bildung in
deutschland voranbringen sagt stefanie
hubrich kultusministerin
bildungsministerin in rheinland pfalz
und präsidenten der
kultusministerkonferenz
ich danke ihnen dass sie heute abend
noch zeit für uns hatten zwar gerne so
und dann schauen wir mal zu meinem
kollegen theo koll in berlin ich fast
noch mal für alle die geradezu
zugeschaltet haben ganz kurz zusammen
die bundeskanzlerin hat sich mit
bildungsministerium carlitscheck und spd
chefin saskia esken mit den
kultusministern der länder zusammen
gesetzt und hat mehrere handlungsstränge
heißt es in der pressemitteilung
identifiziert es wird mehr geld geben
für ausstellung der lehrkräfte es wird
mehr geld geben für kinder die keine
eigenen endgeräte haben also tablets
oder ipads es wird also definitiv auch
mehr geld geben für die technische
infrastruktur der schulen und auch für
mehr glasfaser es klingt alles sehr
vielversprechend ich frage unseren
korrespondenten in berlin theo koll theo
wie bewertest du jetzt diese
ankündigungen ist das der große wurf auf
den wir alle gewartet haben
nein der ist heute hier nicht geliefert
worden es ist sind handlungsstränge wie
man das eben in der gemeinsamen
erklärung formuliert hat die hat man auf
gesetzt und beschlossen sind ganz wenig
wirklich konkrete beschlüsse
es war ja auch im grunde hier heute
abend ein gremium das er eigentlich
nicht wirklich etwas beschließen kann es
sind einerseits die kultusminister die
müssen aber sich in den ländern wieder
absichern
es war die kanzlerin dabei es war die
spd-chefin dabei die viel angeregt hat
auch in dieser digitalisierungs frage
also sind eine ganze menge von
absichtserklärungen der bund hat auch
viel geld wieder in aussicht gestellt
insgesamt muss man sagen ist zu spüren
dass wir ein schulsystem haben das zu
einem nicht unerheblichen teil noch in
der kreidezeit war und dass wir auch
eben durch diese user frage sehr
deutlich geworden ist im grunde einen
digitalisierungs schock hier erlebt hat
und deswegen bekommen wir all diese
maßnahmen also laptops dienst geräte für
lehrer laptops für schüler für kinder
die sich das zuhause nicht erlauben
können
was ist jetzt heute hier gegeben hat
interessanterweise sind wirklich
flatrates für schüler die zu hause
unterrichtet werden müssen weil in der
schule dann fernunterricht angesagt wird
das heißt es gibt dann flatrates von 10
euro oder weniger
die dann vielleicht auch noch übernommen
werden können also das ist sicherlich
hilfreich für schüler die künftig zu
hause unterrichtet werden müssen soll
auch die möglichkeit geben von
nachhilfeunterricht für bedürftige
schüler also es sind ein paar dinge sind
erreicht worden aber insgesamt spürt man
dass wir in einem föderalen system da
sagen wir mal nicht zu großem tempo und
neigen
eine frage noch liegt das tatsächlich
das daran dass alle bundesländer da ihr
eigenes süppchen kochen und sich einig
werden müssen oder ist es ist dann
einfach noch nicht tatsächlich die
dringlichkeit der situation erkannt
worden
ich glaube es liegt beiden dingen also
einerseits ist unser bildungssystem
föderal aufgeteilt die länderinteressen
sind auch unterschiedlich das heißt die
bildungsminister die heute abend hier
waren die müssen jetzt in ihrer länder
gehen und müssen die dinge ja auch
beispielsweise mit den
gesundheitsministern oder den jeweiligen
ministerpräsidenten abstimmen das heißt
wir haben bundesländer
da gibt es sehr geringe infektionszahlen
die haben eigentlich nicht das gefühl
dass sie eine ähnliche hygiene
notwendigkeit in den schulen haben
müssten was masken betrifft usw als
andere länder wo hohe infektionszahlen
sind also da gibt es unstimmigkeiten die
kultusminister hier können eigentlich
relativ wenig eigenständig entscheiden
und dann haben wir den bund der immer
stärker erkennt es ist ganz viel geld
nötig im system damit das erreicht wird
und das war heute im grunde auch wenn
wir die die spritze die von von verbund
gekommen ist der aber eigentlich gar
nicht zuständig ist also wir haben da
ein schwieriges system und dann tempo
war dieses system nicht gewöhnt und
krone hat er wirklich eine neue
notwendigkeit gebracht wenn man jetzt
erlebt beispielsweise die diskussion in
den klassenräumen ums lüften manche
schulen haben gar nicht die möglichkeit
ordentlich zu lüften weil die fenster
nicht so ausgelegt sind
die diskussion ob man nicht in jedes
klassenzimmer so einen hochwertigen
filter stellt der dia rosol
herausfiltert das dauert alles
wahnsinnig lange bis das bis das hier
angekommen ist bis das verstanden ist
bis es umgesetzt ist also ich glaube da
ist noch luft nach oben
gut dann halten wir uns diesmal
vielleicht nicht an das sprichwort gut
ding will weile haben
theo koll vielen dank für die
einschätzungen heute abend und dann
schauen wir noch mal was unsere lehrerin
in nürnberg verena knoblauch und
digitalisierungs experten zu den
beschlüssen sagt wir haben gerade
gehörte surf flatrate geben für
schüler/innen es wird mehr geld geben
für n
geräte für ausstattung von technischen
administrationen aber das hat ja mein
kollege theo koll gerade schon da sagt
sind nur handlungsstränge und es sind
alles ja im grunde so ein bisschen er
empfehlungen und ein bisschen wir
schauen mal wie es funktioniert bist du
enttäuscht oder wirst du froh dass
überhaupt was passiert naja ich glaube
jeder schritt ist wichtig wenn das
wirklich so sein wird dass die
zusammenarbeit gestärkt wird dass man
vielleicht auch diese lernplattformen
und die inhalte die es da gibt
zusammenlegt das wäre glaube ich ein
ganz wichtiger schritt
auch die ausstattung ist natürlich total
wichtig weil ohne technische ausstattung
funktioniert so was nicht
ich glaube was wir uns ganz dringend
bewusst machen müssen ist aber dass die
technische ausstattung alleine einfach
nicht ausreicht also die ist wenn ich
sonst gar nicht kann digital unterricht
machen das ist völlig klar
aber alleine nur das hilft nicht und ich
glaube dass es ganz zentral wichtig sich
das bewusst zu machen dass hier
fortbildungen brauchen sowohl für die
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir brauchen aber auch die zeit um den
kindern das beizubringen
und das darf man nicht und natürlich
fallen lassen das ist eigentlich
mindestens genauso wichtig wie die
technische ausstattung und dann brauchen
wir auch eine zeit den kolleginnen die
zeit zu geben damit sie sich damit
beschäftigen können und auch wie gesagt
man sich vor solchen angesprochen habe
auch die rückendeckung sich das auch
zutrauen so mal off topic wir haben hier
user bedürfnisse nach der katze ist die
noch da ja alle nicht wo okay vielleicht
kann ich ja gleich nochmal ich gehe noch
mal jetzt abschließend durch die
kommentare hier ist einiges aufgelaufen
also andreas schreibt auf facebook wie
so haben wir bürger den eindruck dass
die sommerferien von den politikern
verpennt wurden statt das thema
erweitert so gesprächen besser zu
verstehen und sich verändernde situation
gleich die richtigen pläne auszuarbeiten
so ist das auch einfach denn sie haben
ok
vielen dank aber ich bin kein politiker
aber es ist auch dein eindruck dass das
verpennt wurde das dass der eindruck von
andreas h
ich glaube verpennt ist hart ausgedrückt
ich glaube dass das diese ganzen
prozesse einfach so lange dauern und
dann wohl da im hintergrund
wahrscheinlich wie viel gearbeitet aber
es kommt bin ich raus und dann hat man
das schönes oder zu kennen facebook eva
maria zimmermann schreibt wie kann es
sein dass die lehrkräfte so alleine
gelassen werden mit dem digitalen
unterrichten die ministerien müssten
einer lernplattform zur verfügung
stellen die datenschutzrechtlich in
ordnung ist da haben wir ja jetzt eure
gelernt es soll eine schrittweise
entwicklung an der bildungsplattform
durch den bund geben wo sich die systeme
vernetzen können ob das jetzt genau das
gleiche ist kann ich gerade nicht
beantworten dafür ist diese
pressemitteilung noch ein bisschen zu
kryptisch gutes beschwert sich gibt ja
auch viele lernplattformen der bayern
hat nebels anderes verein hat eine
plattform also es gibt ja durchaus all
diese plattformen und es gibt auch
unterstützung es gibt netzwerk ich
sofort bildung aber natürlich das klingt
alles macht sein klein muss ich sagen
aber dann schaue ich noch mal weiter
linux an fragt sich doch auf facebook
ich frag mich wie sowie sowie die
digitalisierung nicht bereits in den
schulen erlernt willkommen in anderen
ländern wie china zum beispiel lernt man
im sehr jungen alter das programmieren
und es wäre schön wenn es hier auch mal
so wäre das lassen wir einfach mal so
stehen
[Musik]
tablets bringen kein digital unterricht
schreibt eine person auf youtube wo sind
die konzepte das ist glaube ich auch
einfach mal ein kommentar den wir so
stehen lassen und jetzt hier maik
gremmel auch auf youtube meine tochter
hat kostenloses internet wir haben genug
genügend equipment was fehlt sind
koordinierte inhalte und dass die
lehrkräfte und schulen auch die pläne
umsetzen können so das ist glaube ich
wohl das dickste brett was zu bohren ist
oder wir ihn ja das ist ja im prinzip
das was ich gerade meinte die technische
ausstattung alleine richtet nicht ganz
triviale aussage dass digitalisierung
oder digitale geräte aller einen guten
unterricht machen sondern dann braucht
es eben auch die idee dahinter man
machen möchte und das müssen die
kolleginnen auch und die kollegen
natürlich auch lernen aber das war ja
interessant gerade was vermutlich gesagt
hat die konzepte machen die meiste
arbeit da hat es dann auch tatsächlich
teilweise gewandelt weil man nun mit den
konzepten die mittel bekommt und
teilweise fehlen die auch aber es ist
eben auch eine harte arbeit das ganze zu
erarbeiten
ich würde sagen für heute abend machen
wir diesen ziemlich langen live stream
erst mal zu sagen vielen dank wir ihn
hassen wir uns ausgeharrt hat und darauf
habe ich gewartet und bedanke mich fürs
zuschauen für die ganzen fragen
kommentare und sagt dass zum nächsten
live stream
schönen abend noch bis bald und schüssen